we are working on a new homes
construction community that incorporates
solar roof on all the projects solar
roof is a photo vitalic system which
have been modified into a aesthetic
package on average the systems are about
a 14 kwatt system each on 10 homes so
roughly we've installed about 140 Kow
all together on these houses for this
community safety is utmost priority we
have exact guideline what is expected
with anchor placement figure eight knots
everything that is necessary to make
sure you do not fall off that roof we
work straight busines to business with
our home builders so we provide them a
dedicated service and the ability to
work alongside all of their other
construction trades during the house
build so that when the home is complete
they've got a turnkey system for those
homeowners when they take the keys to
the
home so it's important for a home to be
less riing on the grid for multiple
reasons whether it's shortterm or
longterm you're saving money but also
things do happen power goes out whether
it be storms the customers aren't even
going to know if they lose power in
addition to the Tesla solar roof we also
got power wall and Tesla wall connector
I definitely feel more secure knowing
that we have power stored in the power
wall just in case there is any kind of
outage but I've also noticed that I've
just become a lot more power aware
because since I can see how much we're
using actively at any point during the
day it's also an opportunity for us to
teach our children and how to be energy
conscious and kind of reduce our
footprint on the
planet